so pilar we're both going to demonstrate
two different things that you could
treat yourself with and these are treats
for galentines valentine's palentines
yup so on deck today we have a brie
an apple grilled cheese sandwich i mean
no truer expression of love than a
grilled cheese sandwich
and when we cut the sandwich when we
made it the other day we realized that
the bread cuts into the shape of a heart
which is absolutely
just for valentine's day and then the
second recipe
is a citrus and olive oil loaf this
is like my go-to easy enough for a
weekday
special enough for a weekend recipe and
it's inspired by two
culinary uh powerhouses melissa clark
and dory greenspan well i have to say
that olive oil cake is so hot right now
it's so on trend and this sandwich is
something i made for myself
when i was pregnant so that should just
tell you everything now
here we go all right you want soft
butter definitely room temp
not melted do not put butter in the pan
i'm very passionate about this
because what you don't want on crunchy
bread
is soggy butter to make it all wet
and nasty you want to take a room temp
and spread the butter right on the slice
of bread i mean and that's what's going
to give you a great grill
that isn't wet and oily what kind of
bread are you using drew
i like a nice store-bought sourdough
yeah
and it has that really nice tang too
which i think it adds to the flavor of
the whole grilled cheese
sandwich that's looking really good
thank you
okay so then you want to have it like on
a nice
medium to high not medium to low because
you want
some crunch and crisp so get the pan
going
then you want to take your brie and make
that the first layer
the brie is also going to act like a
glue
for the arugula which is kind of a nice
touch
i personally don't prefer the skins but
it's okay if a little bit gets on there
like you're not going to be able to get
it perfect it's brie
one quick tip about um if you're taking
the skins off or the rinds off of debris
how do you have any bree left you
definitely want it
a little more chilled and that's gonna
do a really nice and easy slice so that
you can take the rind off
much easier and i love the brief flavor
because it doesn't fight the pepperiness
of the arugula
and the sweetness and acidity of the
apple so
i go hard on the arugula like get
yourself
a nice pile because you want that green
you want that
little bit of that beautiful texture
that the arugula
provides and apple and brie are such
classic combinations but if you wanna if
you wanna play around the litter
a little you can do like a pear and
gruyere
i'm starting to rhyme pear and gruyere
pear and green yeah now i'm not feeling
as confident in my sandwich
right now apple apple and brie is like
it's so delicious and if you've removed
your pan and it's gone
a little cooler don't worry oh
that's sizzle it's talking to you it is
so drew one another tip sorry to wrap it
but i wanted to mention this to people
is some people have the urge to put a
lid on
pilar what does putting a lid on it do
it basically
steams it which is exactly what you do
not want in a grilled cheese sandwich no
you do not yeah so i think pressing
gently
is totally great and that's going to go
for about two to three minutes i think
each side roughly so while you're
grilling i'm going to start on our
citrus olive oil loaf cake so in this
bowl we have
3 4 cup of sugar and the zest
of two oranges is that a blood orange
no so these are grapefruits and two
navel oranges basically
and nice and nice and sweet so what you
want to do when you get the sugar in the
bowl
is to actually rub that zest with the
sugar because it starts to
perfume the sugar and release the oils
so to that we're going to add over here
we have
half a cup of just plain yogurt
get that in there i'm going to mix that
up
and to this as i'm mixing i have
a quarter cup of the citrus juice
from the citrus that we segmented
earlier
so drew to this batter i'm just adding
in three eggs
carrying on over here mixing mixing
and then we're gonna add in two-thirds
cup of olive oil so you don't want to
break your bank with this olive oil but
you do
want a nice flavorful olive oil because
that
that's going to carry all throughout the
cake
okay now we're going to fold in our dry
ingredients where you have some flour
some baking powder so that's 1 3 4 cup
of flour
a teaspoon and a half of baking powder
quarter teaspoon of baking soda and a
quarter teaspoon of salt
basically so i'm going to mix that in
the bowl
and do the last thing we're going to do
to this batter is actually
fold in gently that wasn't so gentle
your citrus segments your navel oranges
my navel oranges and my pink grapefruit
okay now i am gonna cut this polar help
me because the last time we cut it
you cut it perfectly where it went into
hearts and i went too much on an
angle and you want it on exactly on the
bias
exactly on the bias yeah mine looked
like
so weird because i went great too much
for the diagonal
um and this bread
okay so there's the cut oh that's
beautiful drew
and i'm just pouring this batter into
the prepared
pan oh yeah oh yeah that looks great
this thing to finish off is going to go
into a 350 degree
oven for how long for around 50 minutes
until it gets golden and did you say
15 50. five five oh five
i clarified that it's not that simple
it's gonna start to pull away from the
pan it's gonna get golden and then
you're gonna wanna
test it with a cake tester and it's
going to come out clean
i mean i'm using my fish spatula
yes just for fish
um and then what's the way that it go oh
you know what
just flip it over there you go now it's
in there's that
card perfect
did you see the lovely citrus segments
coming through i feel like we have an
art theme going on
i do think we have painting with a
mustard we have these like lovely
squiggles
so you can take the palette knife and
just paint on it or you can just take
your sandwich
and drag it through and i'm gonna do my
little
dress drizzle drizzle you ready one up
cheers i love you
galentines happy galentines
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
thank you pilar you're welcome i love
you love you